un conseil de défense consacré à la
crise alimentaire s'est tenue ce jour
autour du président de la république
comme nous le faisons à intervalles
réguliers nous avons analysé l'évolution
de la situation épidémiologique
celle ci fait apparaître une dégradation
manifeste
le virus circule de plus en plus en
france le taux d'incidence est monté à
72 cas pour 100000 personnes contre 57
il y a une semaine
le pourcentage des cas positifs ne cesse
d'augmenter
un élément suscite particulièrement
notre inquiétude pour la première fois
depuis de longues semaines
nous constatons une augmentation
sensible de personnes hospitalisées
or les personnes qui arrivent en
réanimation sont les mêmes qu'au mois de
mars
tout confirme que le virus n'a pas
baissé en intensité avec une proportion
toujours aussi élevé de personnes âgées
cela signifie qu'il n'y a pas de ligne
maginot
même si le virus circule principalement
chez les jeunes dont beaucoup ne
présente
heureusement aucun symptôme il finit
inévitablement par toucher les personnes
les plus vulnérables pour lesquels le
virus présente véritable danger face à
cette épidémie
notre stratégie ne varie pas lutter
contre le virus hin1 évitant de devoir
mettre entre parenthèses notre vie
sociale culturelle économique
l'éducation de nos enfants et notre
capacité à vivre normalement
oui le virus est là pour quelques mois
encore et nous devons réussir à vivre
avec lui sans nous laisser entraîner à
nouveau dans une logique de confinement
généraliser la solution la plus simple
et la moins contraignante
on la connaît c'est appliquer
scrupuleusement les gestes barrière cela
dépend fondamentalement de nous je l' ai
déjà dit la période estivale a été
marquée par une forme de relâchement que
l'on peut probablement expliqué après
les longues semaines de confinement au
printemps dernier
la rentrée est là nous devons
impérativement respecter les règles de
distanciation physique nous laver
régulièrement les mains
nous devons porter le masque ce que
l'immense majorité de nos concitoyens
fait en application des dispositions que
nous avons prises et je les en remercie
l'autre pilier de notre stratégie cette
dépister massivement et casser ainsi les
chaînes de contamination nous réalisons
aujourd'hui plus d'un million de tests
par semaine c'est considérable et la
france est ainsi devenu le troisième
pays qui testent le plus en europe
cette très forte augmentation du nombre
de tests est une excellente nouvelle
elle a cependant entraîné des temps
d'attentes trop important nous en avons
parfaitement conscience notamment dans
certaines villes attendre ce n'est pas
grave s'il n'y a pas urgence
mais ces problématiques lorsque vous
êtes prioritaire quand êtes-vous
prioritaire
êtes prioritaire si vous présenter les
symptômes de la cop vide
si vous avez été en contact rapproché
avec une personne positive ou enfin si
vous êtes c'est un personnel soignant ou
assimilés travaillant à l'hôpital dans
un ehpad ou à domicile
pour ces personnes prioritaires nous
allons renforcer les circuits dédiés de
dépistage ainsi les laboratoires leur
réserveront certains créneaux horaires
et nous veillerons là où il y a des
besoins et notamment dans les grandes
villes a installé des tentes de
dépistage qui leur seront également
dédiés pour les personnes testées
positives et celles avec lesquelles
elles ont été en contact
le conseil de défense a pris deux
décisions pour améliorer la surveillance
épidémiologique première décision 2000
recrutements supplémentaires seront
effectués au sein de l'assurance maladie
et des agences régionales de santé pour
réaliser ce qu'on appelle le traçage
deuxième décision sur proposition du
conseil scientifique la durée
d'isolement sera ramené à 7 jours
c'est à dire la durée pendant laquelle
il y à un véritable risque de contagion
il est primordial que chacun respecte
strictement cette durée d'isolement ce
qui donnera lieu à des contrôles par
ailleurs le conseil de défense a porté à
42 le nombre de départements classés
rouge c'est-à-dire à circulation dite
active du virus
ce classement n'en portent pas de
conséquence automatique mais il permet
au préfet en lien avec les autorités
sanitaires et des élus locaux de
déclencher des mesures supplémentaires
de réduction des risques notamment sur
le port du masque les rassemblements sur
l'espace public
les grands événements ou les horaires
d'ouverture de certains commerces comme
je l' ai toujours dit ces mesures ne
doivent pas se décider depuis paris dans
l'idée de s'appliquer partout au même
moment et de la même manière nous
conserverons cette méthode qui devra
nous permettre d'agir sans attendre que
les choses se dégradent dans deux
métropoles marseille et bordeaux ainsi
qu'en guadeloupe
nous constatons à ce jour une évolution
préoccupante des contaminations
notamment chez les plus âgés ainsi qu'un
taux déjà élevé d'hospitalisations
compte tenu des prévisions que nous
pouvons faire à trois semaines sur
l'occupation des lits de réanimation
j'ai demandé aux préfets concernés de me
proposer d'ici lundi
et après avoir mené les concertations
locales nécessaires
un ensemble de nouvelles mesures
complémentaires
nous continuerons à prendre les mesures
adaptées et graduées en fonction de
l'évolution de la situation sanitaire et
de son anticipation ainsi que je l'ait
annoncé le ministre chargé de la santé
reprendra ses points d'information
régulier j'en appelle aujourd'hui
solennellement au sens des
responsabilités de chacune et chacun
d'entre vous nous ne parviendrons à
enrayer cette reprise de l'épidémie
qu'un étant tous vigilants et solidaires
je demande en particulier aux personnes
âgées d'observer la plus grande prudence
au quotidien faites attention soyez très
prudents pour quelques mois encore nous
devons faire preuve d'une responsabilité
tous les instants d'incivisme exigeant
demain dépend de vous de nous je vous
remercie